yet another ET exclusive we are first on
the set of Ben Affleck's new movie the
accountant I guess I just thought this
was something that was really original
you know which is a rare thing this
seemed to have genuinely unique elements
and to be genuinely surprising that's
been behind the scenes better than
Batman and taking on the role no one saw
coming
I have difficulty socializing with other
people even though I want to then plays
Christian Wulff he's a CPA who often
cooks and then uncooked the books for
some of the world's most dangerous
criminals but the mild-mannered math
genius has a secret it's incredible look
it's just it jumps right out at you you
know easy pigeonhole us being a guy
who's limited who's who's less than and
in fact we find out that he's capable of
so many things
despite the roles complexity Ben looked
happy and upbeat on location John
Lithgow and Anna Kendrick co-star she
plays a young clerk I have a pocket
protector that's a nice one he can
barely look at me in some scenes because
you know his character is so
uncomfortable but Ben finds a way to
make the oddities so charming why would
your clients follow you you're an
accountant she's one of my favorite
actresses she's an awesome girl and an
awesome actress and she's perfect in
this part and she's this kind of awkward
counterpoint use sarcasm a theoretician
really it's it's a movie about how he
has to reconcile his past with who he is
now no his character is not warm and
fuzzy also did you know this that Ben
and his buddy Matt Damon have this
little running feud see they're both
wicked crazy Patriots fans and they both
think that they are Tom Brady's best
friend and of course that can lead to
some really weird moments watch if your
chin was anything like Tom's that Batman
movie yours would have made about 4
billion dollars
Tommy's a superhero can you hear
yourself do you really want to have this
argument
it's all in fun of course but the video
is part of a new OU mains charity drive
you can spend a day with Ben Matt and
Tom which is pretty doggone cool